Fox News Alert an avalanche of news
today we'll get to the stunning Steinle
verdict out in San Francisco in just a
moment but we begin with the breaking
new developments on the Moller
investigation in Washington today former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
appeared in federal court and pleaded
guilty to lying to the FBI about his
conversations with Russia's ambassador
during the transition last December his
plea agreement indicates he is providing
information to the special counsel
that's advancing the investigation chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge was inside the courtroom
earlier and joins us now with the very
latest details anything new Catherine
since we spoke at two o'clock well one
of the most interesting developments
comes out of reporting by another one of
our colleagues Brett there we were able
to get information that in the spring of
this year FBI director James Comey
testified in a closed-door session that
his agents had concluded that Flynn made
some sort of bad decisions or didn't
remember things properly seemed kind of
confused about the timeline of events in
December but they didn't believe he had
deliberately misled them that's
significant because if you fast forward
to today about seven months later the
Special Counsel investigators under
Robert Muller have concluded something
very different that there was a
deliberate effort by Flynn to mislead
the FBI about Flynn's contacts with the
Russian ambassador and Flynn agreed in
court today
what I would say about his appearance in
court today is that he was very composed
he seemed to really reach inside himself
and have that soldiers discipline and
that 33 years of service in the military
allowed him to hold it together as he
made that guilty plea which is a felony
the other interesting thing we're
looking at tonight is that in the court
records that were unsealed they're
references to what appeared to be two
members of the Trump transition team a
more junior person who received
information from Flynn at Maher Largo in
December about these conversations with
the Russian ambassador we believe that
to be KT McFarland at this point and
then a more senior person who was
directing Flynn to reach out to a number
of countries including Russia and we
believe that to be jerod cush
but I would give you this caveat we were
told that it wasn't like Kushner was
saying to Flynn you go out and just talk
to the Russians it was a kind of
divvying up of the phone calls there
were different teams for different
countries and they were all tasked with
a certain amount of outreach at that
time so it's it's not quite as sort of
sinister sounding perhaps as it is in
the black and white of the court
documents but we believe the very senior
person was Jared Kushner and that he
testified to that in his session with
the special counsel in November Dana all
right Catherine Herridge thanks so much
we'll take it on the table I worked at
the Justice Department for about a year
and no to approach these things with
caution so I don't I'm just waiting to
see what else is gonna happen out of
this I don't think that we know the full
story yet what do you think Greg well I
always like to focus on the media in the
media they remind me of a contestant on
prices right they were expecting a brand
new car which was Russian collusion and
it said they got a crock pot which is a
lie a single crime committed by pleading
guilty to it a single isolated event
that has nothing to do with Russian
collusion because it happened after the
election so they said they The Ecstatic
media is going to be ecstatic for a few
days but then it's gonna wear off and
they're gonna realize that this is a far
cry from what they really wanted and
they're actually seeding turf on this
that this is far from what they dreamt
net but what really bugs me about this
is if you look at why the meeting took
place why were the contacts made was it
anything nefarious though it was
something noble impossible I mean
something I in my opinion Noble and
correct was to get Russia involved in
fighting terror and fighting Isis and
actually their version of a reset button
that actually made kind of sense which
we may or may not have happened I don't
know but that's what this was about
in my opinion Chuck are you giving me
that weird look you give people on your
show you say that to the people you're
about to yell at you say I agree
completely in this case it's heartfelt I
actually think that the general Flynn
did do something wrong in fact
indefensible he took money from a
foreign government to influence American
policy mm-hmm when he was on his way to
being national security adviser from the
Erdogan government in Turkey I don't
think you can defend that I'm ashamed
that he did that and that's somebody
being punished for he's being punished
for lying which is the classic charge
you level when you don't really have the
underlying charge proved but more to the
point is there a crime in contesting
Russia to talk about how to coordinate
your efforts in Syria against Isis that
seems not just maybe he's getting the
chance to do this guilty plea because of
something there's a lot bucks me is the
idea that speaking to Russia is in it I
don't think what the prosecuting
documents are saying I think what are
they saying the prosecuting document
saying that he lied to FP lie to the FBI
number one and I think they're they use
that as sort of a carrot and stick to
say we will charge you for just this one
crime so you could tell us what else you
know and in his statement to the press
he indicated I plan on working fully
cooperating with the special counsel but
what's not don't know that yet because
it's still sealed and not to mention the
fact that talking and when you are a
transition in government when the Obama
tration was still the government in
control talking to a foreign agency
about what a foreign entity about what
you can't will you will and will not do
is against the Logan Act which is act
that says only one administration can
talk to a foreign government at one time
so he did violate a law but we'll have
to see what Muller does how is it any
more different than when Obama said I'll
have more flexibility after you know the
election I mean I think that Greg brings
up a really great did he say that Obama
said to Mike Mike moment what do you
mean is that any different well what I
mean is that it's a transition and
they're signaling to these people on
these other countries that you know
policies are gonna change I think that
Greg brings up a really good point about
and do Rachel thing I think there is a
giddiness kind of like the giddiness we
saw with Rachel Maddow when she thought
she had the big taxes thing I think
you're right they got a crock pot here
because in the end what they really want
to do is not Russia what they really
want to do is stop the Trump agenda and
Trump was just a vehicle for this agenda
the American people still want all the
things that Trump wants to do they still
want those policies and those ideas to
come forward so whether all this Russia
stuff happens or not I think it leads
the Democrats again down this little
this little Street off of what they need
to do and what they need to do is figure
out why they lost working class
Americans all right because we know
that's why they lost the election so
Rachel I'll give you that and I've said
that before I think Democrats need to
work on our messaging we need to learn
how to talk to blue-collar voters and
some white-collar voters and I'm not
impeachment Democrat and I'm like let's
go impeach him I'm actually waiting for
all the facts that I'm gonna so that
over and over again but when you look at
where we are right now
the fact that Mike Flynn one of the
highest officials in Donald Trump's and
national security apparatus has said
he's going to work with the private
special counsel prosecuting or looking
into this Russia collusion I think
that's a big deal I think is that what
he you said I've been looking to
collusion with Russia collusion about
what the contacts that we know if two
figures are Russia it was my question
you and then you could inform me of this
what would the collusion look like
potentially that's what we were trying
to figure but this is I think after it
was after the election so what would
they be colluding on exactly that's how
this started the whole premise was about
the election but they really don't care
about the election this is about
unseating a president I'm sorry that's
not just I have to say that that's just
not true because if you look at all the
you're looking at the Flynn indictment
in a vacuum and you can't do that you
have to look at Flynn you have to look
at Papadopoulos you have to look at mana
for mana Ford was indicted for things
that happen during the convention prior
to the election Papadopoulos he was in
meetings prior to the election so let's
before we sit here and say oh you can't
look at Flynn in a van no that's what
Dana's saying we don't know what it
means we are we have a expert prosecutor
the best in the country what might it
mean like what's the worst part I don't
want to make any assumption the Sochi
Olympics that's what I mean I mean I'm
sorry I don't think there's any
confusion to be had here I think what
Muller Muller is looking into whether or
not Trump and his associates talk to the
Russians work with the Russians colluded
with the Russia about what
you all already know that the Russians
engage in our election in the
jeopardized our democracy number we
don't know the DNI what he and I said at
multiple intelligence agencies over and
over has said that the Russians tried to
compromise our election can I tell you
what Trump really is guilty a fact is a
fact
Trump is guilty of bad judgment a lot of
people told him not to give that very
high-level position rieflin but this is
a very common rookie mistake Dana you
know this year in politics in that a lot
of candidates first time can't remember
we're talking about a first-time
candidate he's our president but he's a
first-time candidate you feel very loyal
to the people that brought you you know
to victory and so I think he had Trump
had a very typical first candidate
mistake of giving a job to somebody who
was on the campaign who probably
shouldn't had that job and look he only
lasted 20-some days so they reversed
course he was lobbying for the Turkish
government what he should not totally I
wish he were being punished for the
actual crime but maybe the reason that
he's not being punished for the actual
crime is for some reason that we don't
know I mean this is why this takes a
long time it might be wrapped up sooner
than we think but remember it was also
President Obama who told President Trump
be careful of this guy it's Sally Yates
who goes to them at the White House
right goes to the White House from the
Justice Department and says I think you
guys have a problem here she gets fired
the president's calling for Comey to go
easy on Flynn back and that's how they
end up with the special counsel I don't
know how all of this pulls together but
it's certainly not nothing and by the
way if it's I agree nothing here when
you're calling to Russia to say hey
we'll make sure we have established
contact no problem somebody like Mike
Flynn who is a seasoned Patriot 33 years
in the military why lie about that
that's the thing that I don't understand
but he pled guilty to it today why isn't
the FBI but why is it Mueller also or do
we know if he is no but why the
underlying though why lie well they're
threatening so let me let me put it this
way why lie I haven't
I haven't the faintest idea you know
having known a number of people who've
been busted on the line to a federal
agent thing and I don't want to appear
to be defending someone I just attacked
for lobbying for Turkey but I we are
vesting far too much trust in the FBI do
you have any idea what it looks like
when they come after do you know anyone
who's been going after by the FBI very
well-versed my question is you know I
like the FBI and I support American law
enforcement but which is a potentially a
greater threat to you Mike Flynn or the
FBI it's not a close call so I don't
think we should just assume that because
someone has pled to lying that there's
an actual crime in that he said he's a
broken man his house is under he's
selling his house his finances are in
trouble these are all very good
motivations to you know cooperate all
right well I think we're gonna finish
that up right okay my tomorrow